mal y un país marcado por años de malos
gobiernos pobreza corrupción nepotismo y
una insurgencia yihadista que va a peor
la ira contra el ejecutivo de libre
invocar keita había ido en aumento
durante años la exasperación alcanzó un
punto de quiebre después de las
elecciones parlamentarias en la
primavera de 2020
el líder opositor son my last y se fue
secuestrado antes de la primera vuelta
de las elecciones mientras que en la
segunda ronda de los comicios se
vivieron alteraciones en los puestos de
votación del norte y en el centro del
país una vez que se conoció el desenlace
acordé constitucional de malí revirtió
los resultados en 30 distritos
electorales en muchos casos en favor del
partido gobernante de ibrahim bubacar
fue la gota que colmó el vaso en mayo el
conocido imán magnético selló una
alianza con los partidos opositores y le
pidió la renuncia el presidente de los
mandos de nuestra meta no es impulsar a
que una persona o un clan gobierne el
país actuamos por amor a mal en google
fue el comienzo del llamado movimiento
del 5 de junio una coalición de
políticos miembros de la sociedad civil
y magnífico quien lideraba protestas
antigubernamentales el 18 de agosto
algunos jóvenes oficiales del ejército
se levantaron en armas en la guarnición
el pueblo de katy arrestando primero a
militares de alto rango y después al
presidente ibrahim keita y al primer
ministro bus hice bajo la bandera de un
nuevo mal y las protestas se
concentraron en bamako la capital y en
una gran muestra de apoyo a los líderes
golpistas esa junta militar entregó el
poder a un gobierno de transición que
debería celebrar elecciones en un plazo
de 18 meses y ahora de nuevo son los
uniformados los que ponen en jaque al
ejecutivo